let me start by saying there is no
greatest movie of all time
the question is just too difficult to
really answer but I still think it's the
most important question in cinema what
makes a movie great there are a number
of concrete aspects of a movie that
turned them from good movies to movies
with a legacy the first is cinematic
influence how did the movie change the
way movies are made if you read anything
about Citizen Kane you'll realize that
it's probably the most innovative movie
of all time
and that's a big reason why it tops
every all-time movie list Citizen Kane
highlights a very clear distinction
between two eras of filmmaking
especially in its cinematography silent
films were very economical with their
editing they either showed their actors
on a simple two-dimensional plane or
used montage cuts to quickly associate
one idea with another and one sound was
introduced in the late 1920s the first
instinct for many directors was just
filming dialogue shot reversed shot with
shallow focus and it was boring here is
your prize sriracha it's indeed an honor
to receive it from the hands of so
beautiful lady how is it that you didn't
use a black arrow today that's my court
of last resort Sir Guy but Orson Welles
and Greg Tolin changed the game in 1941
by bringing back traditional theatrical
staging on to the screen the use of deep
focus camera allowed characters to be
staged in interesting and revealing way
Jane you are the sole owner showing
power dynamics transitions of power
complex visual storytelling and giving
the viewer active participation in the
scene allowing the viewer to choose what
to look at instead of having a close-up
force you to watch one character at a
time wells and tollens weren't the first
to use this technique but they executed
it so effectively that they started a
movement the iconic deep focus and sharp
lighting of film noir movies all
influenced from Citizen Kane not to
mention Wells's use of sound to
transition from one scene to another
which is basically in every single movie
now not to mention the makeup which had
never been done so extensively not to
mention its extensive use of flashback
and unreliable narration which had only
been done majorly in literature once you
think about it there's no question of
its greatness great movies change things
star wars ended a streak of dreary and
sophisticate
movies in the 1970s the Blair Witch
Project changed the horror genre for
good and it looks like Deadpool's going
to change the game when it comes to
marketing a movie and we'll probably see
a lot more r-rated comedies in the
future because of it if a movie changed
what other filmmakers were doing it's
got to be at least a little bit great
the second measure of greatness is the
cultural impact how did the movie change
the actual world it was made not just
the world of cinema like when jaws made
Beach attendance plummet or when Fight
Club made actual Fight Club spring up
around the u.s. personally I think if
the movie Fight Club inspired you to
start your own Fight Club then you're
totally miss reading the movie but
that's a topic for another time all I'm
saying is movies aren't in a bubble
movies can make laws get enacted they
can spread awareness on a massive scale
to billions of people the ones that
catch the attention of enough people are
great even if it's just bringing back
folk music place where
the third and final way is personal
impact it's the way the movie changes
you I think this is the most overlooked
aspect of a great movie because it's
hard to measure but I've always been a
big believer that movies can tell us
more about how to live our lives than
the real world does
I think Juno explores abortion in a more
accessible way than any abortion
pamphlet or any talk show host yeah and
she was like oh hi
babies have fingernails fingernails and
I think that ability to tap into reality
through a story makes a movie one of the
greats and it's the underlying beauty of
cinema a movie doesn't have to change
cinema forever and it doesn't have to
change the world forever but if it
changes you forever it's got to be
pretty great I know this video is going
more sentimental than usual but
greatness is hard to discuss otherwise
there's certainly measurable cinematic
techniques to judge for greatness but at
the end of the day it's the way movies
touch us personally that makes them
great people pick different movies as
their favorite because at that point in
their life that was the movie they
needed to watch to help them out or just
to astound them the most it could be as
simple as a movie that makes you laugh a
lot I find that if I really liked the
movie I think about it constantly after
I've seen it 500 days of summer really
helped me with a bad relationship
because it felt like the movie was
talking about me and explaining
everything I was currently feeling so
perfectly so how about this
I'm normally terrible at keeping up with
social media but tweet about your
favorite movie to my Twitter at swag
thug for life and I'll respond to it
let's talk about great movies and while
I did start by saying there is no
greatest movie of all time it's
definitely the Princess Bride which I'm
not oh it chimed your life thanks for
watching